[Music]
this morning hell of a book and the man
who went from answering calls is a
customer service rep at a cell phone
company to best-selling author to winner
of the national book award
jason mott's latest novel is funny
tragic and deeply personal he never
thought anyone would publish it but its
impact quickly became impossible to
ignore
to get a more complete story in both the
novel and the man
we traveled to coastal north carolina
now for all my bookworms out there our
first guest is newcomer author jason
matt his debut novel the returned will
be published in september 2013. what is
your book the returned about when my
first novel the return came out i was on
tour for like two months and it was this
very frenetic insane process like i had
really gone from
answering phones at verizon wireless and
kind of hating life to suddenly being a
best-selling author with the tv show and
development and all these things going
from hating life answering calls to
best-selling author is not only a
central part of jason mott's latest book
but his life as a customer service
representative for a cell phone company
are you just getting yelled at yes you
are all day
all day long 40 hours a week 365 a year
and we handle specifically new york
metro so it was only
new yorkers on new yorkers all day every
day for three and a half years and i
worked there mott's days soothing
frustrated phone users ended with the
2013 publication of a fantasy fiction
novel about dead relatives who suddenly
reappear
very much alive but i saw you the moment
you saw him
you believed believed what it was turned
into a network tv series called
resurrection
[Music]
the madness that followed being the next
it author touring around the country
shook mott deeply
then there were the deaths in recent
years of eric garner
george floyd and others
mott combined all of it into hell of a
book which interweaves the story of an
author searching for himself
with the odyssey of a young boy whose
parents try to teach him he can be
invisible the idea of invisibility keeps
you safe and this is kind of rooted in
my own growing i was very introverted i
got bullied a fair amount and i always
wanted to just disappear like if i can
just disappear from this moment i'll be
okay the problem with that is when you
disappear you also lose your voice you
lose your presence you use your ability
to speak for yourself that is the
drawback of it hell of a book is both
absurd and alarming with searing
descriptions of what life can be like as
a black american
jumping back and forth between matt's
less life and death personal
fascinations
including a legendary actor you know for
movies like raising arizona leaving las
vegas
and the rock how in the name of zeus's
did you get out of yourself i want to
talk about nicholas cage we can talk
about nick cage all day
[Laughter]
why
because he's an amazing actor the beauty
of nick cage is he understands how the
world sees him and he controls that
narrative you bet i do anytime you can
know how someone else sees you and
really understand it i think that's a
very insightful powerful thing i would
like to dedicate this award to all the
other mad kids
to all the outsiders the weirdos the
bullied
do you want in this book to make people
think do you want to make them mad
all of the above i want to make people
think i want people to laugh i want to
make them really angry and sad
the black experience in particular is a
myriad of things it is not just the
slave narrative and the civil rights
narrative and the inner city narrative
and it is those things but we are also
absurdists we are also comical people we
like film noir and we want to make jokes
about being on book tour as we also want
to be seen as people we want to be able
to interact with police officers and
authority figures without worrying that
our skin may be the thing that gets us
killed what's more fulfilling for you
writing
fantasy fiction or
i mean writing stories about issues that
are life and death all of it quite
frankly like both sides have their own
way of speaking like i grew up as the
nerd who read you know beowulf and the
odyssey and lord of the flies and you
know lord of the rings and all those
kinds of books
and so part of the challenge of being a
minority writer is
you're almost always expected to write
about your minority lens how many
imaginations are we losing to this idea
of like they can only write about their
blackness or they can only write about
their queerness or whatever that thing
is when you're a minority writer you're
not given the freedom to stretch out and
spend years just
writing whatever fantasy it does not
relate to that i mean it's very hard to
do
matt's array of interests are tough to
pin down
he practices jiu-jitsu and is a creative
writing professor at the university of
north carolina wilmington what do you
tell kids these days i tell kids mainly
like there's a reality to being a writer
that the idea the image they have of
writing and the image they have of being
a writer probably is very false and very
skewed
but perhaps more than anything jason
motz is a homebody he spent his entire
life in a town with a population of 600.
you grew up in bolton yes went to school
here at unc wilmington for undergraduate
and graduates yes still live in bolton
yes
never left bolton no
why i like small town life like i've
visited a lot of cities and i've i've
been a lot of places but at the end of
the day
i live on land that is almost four
generations of mod family land like
there is a depth and a richness and
living in this place where you know not
only the people beside you but you know
their children and their grandparents
because the south is a place that is
very much about roots and about the past
and so living in this place where i've
lived i've learned to connect with the
past
today the town of bolton has produced a
singular writer who refuses to be boxed
in
and proves it again with yes
a hell of a book
in that tiny town he has no wi-fi or
broadband access wow at his home so i
actually asked him i said do you
actually like that because sometimes
writers you know don't be distracted he
said no it's a pain
um he would prefer it he is though now
that the pandemic is in a different
phase going to be able to tour a little
bit and we got to go the dish is next
folks the dish is next
[Music]
i love when he said the idea that the
students don't get the image of a writer
that they think it's one thing and then
it's another because you do think about
it you talked about it with minority
writers that there's this expectation
that you can only write about
your experience i i when people always
say what's your favorite kind of story
to do i loved his answer because it's
mine it's i love all stories good
stories yeah
good stories it just feels like he
shouldn't been he shouldn't be boxed
into writing any particular sort and
he's jumped around now the first three
were sort of fantasy fiction yeah this
is a change
um but just the way he sort of melds
these are a lot of complicated subjects
again going from as we said absurd to
alarming not easy he really does it
beautifully
um in this book and you know he was
shocked when it won national book award
but after reading it i mean
delve in he also when he was talking
about being a kid and reading and you
know reading beowulf reading
right whatever it may be you think about
kids now and i think about this a lot
with cell phones and everything else
you want them to read because that's
what helps develop that imagination and
that mind in that way yeah no i
my daughter
said mom can you please take me to the
bookstore i i love you out of nowhere
and i was thrilled and she picked up a
book she's reading more now and i think
we have something to do with that and
the book well the bookstore is where you
make those discoveries right we found
jason mott's book i found jason mott's
book at a bookstore i said this looks
interesting i read it said it's great
let's do it does not feel good yeah